plus au sud au sud de l'ukraine à sa
peau reggiane notre envoyé spécial
julien schell d'âge lien vous avez été
interrompue par ce conseil de défense
russe finalement vladimir poutine ne
prend pas pour le moment la parole vous
nous évoquer la situation à gaza
porridge indiqué un peu plus tôt que
vous avez fait le trajet entre marioupol
il a pourrait déjà à peu près trois
heures trois heures de route expliquez
nous ce que vous y avez vu et l'état
d'esprit aussi sur le terrain
alors elisabeth qu'on a vu ce qu'on a
ressenti c'est évidemment beaucoup de
peur chez les habitants parce que
évidemment même si le scénario avait été
annoncé depuis plusieurs jours des
rumeurs courent et qu'il y avait été
plein dès qu'ils pouvaient arriver à
tout moment sur mario paul qu'il pouvait
y avoir aussi une invasion par la mer et
bien les gens tout simplement n'y croyez
pas hier encore il est tout à fait
normalement et d'utiliser encore que ce
scénario vladimir poutine n'oserait
jamais le maître à le concrétiser et
bien aujourd'hui se sont réveillés dans
ce qu'on peut appeler désormais un
cauchemar avec raymond barre de man qui
retente qui ont retenti à l'est de la
ville on ne peut pas parler d'un
mouvement de panique générale mais il y
avait certainement cette peur qu'on a
ressenti dans les rues de la ville
beaucoup rj11 ceux qui ont choisi de
fuir en tout cas se sont rués sur les
banques mais les retraits sont désormais
limités à 2 me de hryvnias craignant
l'équivalent d'environ 60 euros il ya
aussi eu des queues à la pharmacie et de
très longues files d'attentes on l'a pu
le constater se sont formées aux
stations essence donc je vous le disais
ça fait plusieurs jours que des rumeurs
couraient sur une éventuelle invasion
russe n'est en fait les habitants qui ne
voulaient pas y croire ne s'était pas
vraiment préparé à partir précipitamment
à tout quitter en quelques minutes
seulement les habitants qu'on a croisé
les quelques rares d'habitants qu'on a
pu croiser avant de partir étaient
totalement hagard et tenter de faire de
faire le plus de valises possible mais
finalement ils n'ont pu prendre que le
minimum certains le disaient même partir
mais pour aller où donc j'ai certains
sont venus ici à zaporizhya donc trop
n'avaient nulle part où aller et nous
avait déjà dit que quoi qu'il arrive
même si les russes devaient entrer dans
la ville eh bien il resterait parce
qu'ils n'avaient nulle part où aller
justin animaux rapidement avant de
prendre notre invité david cadier on a
entendu tout à l'heure julien volodymyr
zelensky nous avons besoin de
journalistes pour couvrir cette crise
ont évidemment en pleine guerre de
communication de propagande même parlez
nous de votre travail vous parler de la
peur des ukrainiens on imagine que c'est
une peur aussi que vous avez ressenti
vous en quittant marioupol est ce
compliqué de travailler dans ces
conditions
comment quel est le rapport que vous
avez avec la population à l'ena
volochine côté russe nous disait tout à
l'heure qu'il était extrêmement
difficile de représenter une une chaîne
internationale basée à paris notamment
alors du côté ukrainien fait un peu l'
inverse c'est à dire qu'il est très
facile d'accéder aux gens de les
interroger longuement de leur demeure on
se présente en tant que journaliste
français évidemment pour une chaîne
française qui est diffusé à
l'international et les gens que ce soit
à marioupol ou ailleurs sont très
facilement abordable ils ont envie de
conques aunès leur avis ils ont envie de
donner leurs témoignages qu'ils soient
plutôt pro craignant au chorus il n'y a
jamais eu de de défiance à notre égard
de ce côté-ci de la frontière le métier
de journaliste est plutôt bien vu car
les gens savent aussi que comme vous
l'avez dit il y à cette guerre de
cominak de communication qui fait rage
entre le gouvernement ukrainien d'un
côté et la russie de l'autre et les
habitants ont bien compris que cela
pouvait être dans l'intérêt de parler à
des journalistes occidentaux merci
beaucoup je viens chez d'un mobilisés au
sud de